ladies and gentlemen i just had the best
podcast of my life
the line between insanity and
genius is a very
uh fine line i'm not wearing pants
this was a souvenir from from one of my
that's not what i that's
not what i think it is it should be a
meme face and it says they didn't done
it
and unfortunately no one will be able to
see it because of brian rose
guys the age-old question happened what
happens
when someone who will die for free
speech meets
a fragile ego that can't handle any
criticism
nuclear hypocrisy i don't know how else
to say guys we just got
copyright claimed by london real tv
this is mr free speech the guy who wants
no censorship of any kind i i i don't
know if you remember this maybe you
remember his little tagline jordan you
know i might not agree with everything
you have to say
i don't agree with everything you say i
might not agree with everything you say
but i will defend to the death i will
defend to the death your right to say it
yeah brian i may not agree with
everything you say but i'll defend to
the death you're right to say it rose
censored us on our show and probably
even more disgusting is the fact that
he's made a bunch of influencers think
that he's the king of free speech look
at this guy
this guy right here has like two million
subscribers and he thinks that brian
rose is the first one to ever come up
with this idea of free speech here in
the words of brian rose
i may not agree with everything you have
to say but i will defend to the death
your right to say it hey that wasn't
praying rose who came up with that
pretty sure is like voltaire but we're
dealing with this guy and he says you
know oh i'm the modern free speech
warrior you know
you can trust me you can donate to me
he's taking millions of dollars to build
a digital freedom platform free of
censorship right
except he's censoring other people now
you might be saying to yourself stephen
how do you know maybe it was just an
honest mistake it's all a big
coincidence well we actually have
presidents for that he's done this to
other creators too who have been
critical of him
this is rebel wisdom who i did a video
with he also
faced the wrath of brian rose and he
also got censored
they've issued a copyright claim got
many of our investigations taken down
and also a copyright strike against
rebel wisdom
if you're just an average guy you've
never taken a stance on free speech
maybe it's understandable that you get
offended you just in the
heat of the moment you take down
someone's content but to be the guy
always claiming to be mr free speech
always claiming that you're so
above censorship in fact you raised
millions of dollars
to be above censorship for you to go and
be that guy
to then go and use the copyright system
like this when it was clearly fair use
we were commenting on his little kung fu
movie the entire time
transforming the content the entire time
for you to censor that
that is pure and total hypocrisy one
thing i've understood about freedom of
speech is
it really means freedom of speech for
things you don't want to hear out of
other people's minds
brian
the sheer cognitive dissonance of these
two stances is too much for me to bear
brian it's really easy to say
i can say what i want but but the
question is like you said
will you defend to the death someone
else's right to say something you
fundamentally disagree with
guys i don't know what else to say i
think we need a place free of censorship
i think we need i think youtube's not
enough right youtube just lets anyone
take down your video for any reason i
think we need something better
bit shoot no library no story fire no
i think we need our own digital
freedom platform that's why today
i'm live wouldn't that be hilarious we
started our own rival
digital freedom platform company though
just to put up that one video
of us making fun of brian's karate movie
so yeah i mean i don't know if i need to
call the cast or something like that
let's get dailymotion on the phone
let's uh let's build this thing huh and
look you might be asking yourself why
would brian do this
and i want to submit to you that i think
that he
actually doesn't believe in free speech
at all i think he's using it as a
convenient
tool and i'm gonna try to prove that to
you right now okay
here's evidence one here's him saying
that he studies
like books about psychopaths and uh
manipulation and power he's going to
endorse these two books that really
no sane person would think oh this is a
way to model my life here listen to this
i read american psycho i read the book
pimp by iceberg slim and i saw these as
training manuals
hey pimp and
american psycho or about hey
spoiler psychos
that's what they're about these are
books to show the underbelly of society
not to show you how to treat people
if you guys don't know pimp by iceberg
slim a lot of rappers got inspired by
him
like ice cube all these iced teas they
got inspired by iceberg
slim iceberg slim wrote this book called
pimp
to basically document his experiences as
a pimp and controlling women and
controlling people
this is the book that brian rose says
was his training manual
meanwhile iceberg slim it's not like he
doesn't really glorify it it's just like
an honest account but he doesn't really
glorify
he's like look i could have been a
better person if i had different
upbringing a different upbringing
and meanwhile brian rose is like hey
great some some
manual on how to control people with
manipulation so i wouldn't put
put it past brian to weaponize something
like free speech
you know he's going to say that he's a
big fan he's not actually he's
actually in a big fan as far as it can
serve his devices
and when his devices are no longer
served like in the case of us showing a
video about him kind of mocking him
kind of teasing him a little bit that
all of a sudden he's going to get super
upset about and
now freedom of speech no longer applies
no freedom of speech for me
i also want to show you guys this brian
rose has
also been kind of getting rid of free
speech on his own channel even
he's been deleting a bunch of content
ever since he announced his mayoral run
here
if you look at his social blade you can
see that he deleted a
bunch of videos really recently like all
within october look at all those views
he lost so you might be asking yourself
what videos did he delete and we don't
have a perfect answer for that because
youtube doesn't have a great way to tell
that
but we do have maybe something to look
at because
when you delete a video that's part of a
playlist it doesn't actually
it still shows it as like unavailable
and you can get a good idea of what he
deleted by
what's no longer in video playlists
that's how this works
so i went looking through his playlist
and i said what is brian rose hiding
what's he been deleting
lately and what i found
shocked me brian rose has been deleting
all the conservative podcasts that he
had on
his channel this is brian i'll defend
your death you're right to say it
whatever look at this he deleted his
larry elder podcast
look this video has been removed by the
uploader oops
his dan cranshaw episode his dennis
prager episode
candace owens but it's got a certain
leaning to it right because he's got
other
interviews that you might think of as
maybe a little bit controversial
uh that are still up as long as they
have left-wing views but if they're a
right-winger then all of a sudden he
removes them dave rubin's removed here
we go dave rubin
but basically he's cleaning house of all
the controversial interviews
he's censoring himself and removing
stuff off of his platform so people
can't find it anymore find out what he
believes
now that he's running for mayor look
even david
ike mr david ike the guy who basically
put brian on the map to be honest
brian's career exploded when he got
connected with david ike
where are all the videos with david like
there are 16 no 15 deleted videos with
david ike
and the one that is still up what it's
called
is i i don't agree with everything you
say but i'll defend
to the death you're right to say it
apparently only until it's politically
inconvenient for him and then he'll
delete your video with him
i will say he still has his videos up on
the digital freedom platform i will
give you that but i think there are some
very strategic reasons he's removing
them from youtube and i'm gonna prove in
a second that it's him removing them not
youtube
i think he's doing it because he knows
most people won't
actually go through the his platform
they're gonna go through youtube to find
out what he thinks and so he's curating
this very
palatable public image he knows he's in
the public eye now that he's trying to
run for mayor
and so he's trying to clean out he
doesn't want to be seen associating with
somebody
like david ike because he knows he's
going to be seen as a conspiracy
theorist he knows the optics of it he
might say
that he's mr free speech i'll let david
ike on my platform but in reality he's
trying to distance himself
i don't know david ike david aiku that
kind of stuff
because when you look at these videos
that he's deleted right you look got to
look at these videos that he's deleted
look you might be thinking to yourself
well surely youtube has
deleted all of them right well no
because he's always crying censorship
right and
it's not true that youtube's deleted all
of them look this is a private video a
private anything that says private
automatically you know that
london reel proactively did that then
secondly you can tell even with deleted
videos whether
london reel deleted it or youtube
deleted it for example there's one video
in this playlist that was actually
deleted by youtube it's this one right
here
it says this video has been removed for
violating youtube's community guidelines
but the rest of them the rest of these
deleted videos they say
this video has been removed by the
uploader can you see that
this video has been removed but here's
another one here's another this video
has been removed by the uploader here's
another one uh once again removed what
does this all mean
london reels cleaning house with all of
his uh controversial episodes you know
i don't by the way i don't care if
you're conservative uh republican
democrat a liberal what however you
identify
that's not the point of this channel not
a political thing it's a hypocrisy thing
you can't be mr free speech and then
not actually support free speech on your
channel one thing i've understood about
freedom of speech is
it really means freedom of speech for
things you don't want to hear out of
other people's minds
anyway that's basically it i just want
to give a quick shout out by the way
for the guy who designed this this set
that you're seeing right now
jonathan lampell on twitter you can go
follow him and uh
that's basically it thanks for watching
and don't forget to smash
like and subscribe thank
do you get when you burn through your
plastic
stacks
[Music]
a mouth
[Music]
comes along